the president travels to texas this
morning to see how millions are
recovering
from a deadly cold snap texans shivered
for days
after snow and cold knocked out power
and water and damaged homes
across the state dozens of people died
janet chamleon spoke to one family
that's planning a funeral for a loved
one
killed by the cold while also rebuilding
their own lives
janet good morning anthony good morning
to you beyond the burst pipes in the
waterlogged homes
a devastating human told the deaths from
hypothermia
at least 15 of those here in the houston
area and families telling these
heartbreaking stories
of how their loved ones lost their lives
i miss this phone calls
i never thought i would when isaac abara
couldn't reach his brother gilbert
during the winter storm
he went to the 60 year old's garage
apartment where he found gilbert dressed
in layers
on the floor the medical examiner
reports hypothermia as the cause of
death
gilbert rivera was mentally disabled his
nephew lawrence says
but lived independently i don't think i
would have ever thought
anybody dying of hypothermia in houston
texas
gilbert's death came as lawrence and
isaac's homes were damaged by burst
pipes
they're now recovering from their own
disasters and planning a funeral
gilbert's sister has filed suit against
center point energy and ercot
which manages the texas power grid what
is your goal going into this as you
pursue legal action
our goal is for this not to happen to
other people our goal is for
other people to be able to have power
during
not just winter storms but also during
floods of possibility
just everybody can stay safe and stay
you know
well-being in their own homes and be
able to be safe
we hope that our government and local
government can actually help
make this never happen again ercot says
it hasn't reviewed the lawsuit
a spokesman for center point declined
comment to a texas tv station
everything urcot is under fire for its
handling of the crisis texas lawmakers
challenged executives thursday
on their response to the outages this is
the largest train wreck in the history
of deregulated electricity
ercot claims it has sovereign immunity
that would give it some protection from
lawsuits
the texas supreme court will decide that
later this year and as the president and
first lady spend a good part of the day
here in houston
they will also be visiting the fema mega
site
that is vaccinating up to 6 000 people a
day
gail all right janet thank you very much